who knew that this girl would become one
of the most powerful women in the world
angela merkel has managed to pave her
way to the top and persevere in a
male-dominated world despite many crises
the longer she was in power the more her
reputation around the world grew
she has demonstrated everything that it
takes
to be a leader and she did it
as a woman
nobody will ever think that angela
merkel is weak or something like that
and an entire generation here in germany
has never seen anyone but a woman hold
the office of chancellor
i don't know any chancellor other than
michael
it will be a big change for me when
there's another chancellor
so how did angela merkel make it all the
way to the top in the male dominated
world
when i entered politics in 1990 i
honestly would have imagined everything
to be easier how did she use her power
to promote women's interests i didn't
really see her to be the at the
forefront of fighting for women's rights
why not i don't know
and why did it take her so long to call
herself a feminist do you consider
yourself a feminist
[Music]
i think she's a feminist
i don't think she's a feminist i think
every woman's a feminist
[Music]
in that sense i can say we should all be
feminists
[Applause]
[Music]
some 16 years ago a woman moved into the
upper floor of the german chancellery
until then germany's fate had always
been decided on by men
by the close of the 20th century dozens
of countries around the world including
sri lanka india pakistan the united
kingdom and israel had already seen
women hold the top leadership roles in
their governments
by 2005 germany seemed ready for its
first female chancellor or was it
the fact of the matter center right cdu
together with its sister party the ecsu
won narrowly ahead of the center left
social democrats
and mecca's predecessor gerhart
schroeder refused to believe it what a
adverse mayor
do you really think that under these
circumstances my party would consider an
offer for talks with mrs mackel when
she's saying she would like to be
chancellor
let's not get carried away here
he wouldn't be the last to underestimate
angela merkel some of your rivals even
called her a historical accident
but she would not be held back
merkel became the first female
chancellor in german history
a landmark event
who would have thought that this year
the highest government office would be
taken up by a woman who would have
thought
[Applause]
and no one believed that angela merkel
would remain in power for almost 16
years
thank you it's a tremendous feeling
i'm very satisfied i'm happy
the female chancellor entered the world
without alpha male shrine
and crisis prevail
in her first 11 years in office she was
the only woman leading one of the
world's major economic players
at first
megan had to get used to their power
place
there are significant moments that we
all have in mind one is the
confrontation with putin's dog that was
an insidious move from putin he wanted
to intimidate her and she let herself be
intimidated she's just scared of dogs i
was surprised because she's usually
fearless but of course there are people
who are afraid of dogs maybe there's a
personal experience behind it we can't
know but she hid it you could see it on
her face but she also got through it
italy's former prime minister sylvia
bellusconi kept her waiting
and george w bush gave you an unwelcome
neck massage
he crossed a line her body language made
clear george you can't do that
but she had to endure that she's very
good at enduring things
angela i'm sorry i did that
over time the chancellor has learned
that her best defense against
mansplaining and sexism is to combat
them with humor for example at the g20
summit with russian president vladimir
putin
u.s president donald trump once refused
to shake her hand
subtle messages that have an effect and
are understood around the world
she's a giant among men
so i respect her
i want her to push her hand around to
help other women in the world
i'd like her to keep being an
influential person and hope she keeps
inspiring even more women so they'll
dare to enter this field which is so
difficult
[Music]
i wish the united states would have a
woman president
she's the best in the world
[Music]
during her trips abroad angel america
has repeatedly raised the issue of
women's and girls rights in saudi arabia
she talked to female leaders about the
role of women and their impact in
society
in niger she supported a women's shelter
in south korea she encouraged female
students to enter politics we should not
forget that what she represents has been
a great inspiration for for women who
have tried to follow
some of the things she does and some of
the things she says no one
expected she set the face
for women all over the world
that we can do it
what i admire in her
is that she's so
calm she's so considered
and and yet she seems to be listening to
all the things going on around her all
different opinions coming to the table
and only when you know
everything has been put to the table
then she says well maybe this is the way
forward
and i think that is like that's a very
good approach because that creates
ownership for the solutions that we find
but also
it's probably better solutions so it is
also a very good role model for other
women
to be involved either in politics in the
economy in the area they want because
nobody will ever think that angela
merkel is weak or something like that i
think for the next
leaders it will not be easier
because because first maybe we think
that it's going to be easier because the
glass ceiling has been broken
but i think for the next generation they
are going to be constantly compared with
who break those class initially
and this is i mean like angela merkel is
just for middle leaders so the bar is
very high
angela merkel is still a trade blazer
who inspires many people around the
world to better understand how she
became a woman of power we have to go
back to your past
[Music]
this is templin a small town in former
east germany just an hour and a half
away from berlin angel america grew up
here during the cold war we are here to
talk to people who personally knew her
before she became german chancellor
we are meeting up with america's former
russian teacher hello
hello
after school angela merkel often spent
time at erica ben's house russian was
her favorite subject along with matt she
studied extra hard to be better than
others hardworking highly motivated and
an introvert that's how erica ben
remembers the chancellor as a teenager
again she was
i wouldn't say shy
very reserved
she had good manners
she never interrupted me she never
argued with the others
and when i said that's not enough you
have to study an additional page she did
it all
hard work pays off
yes
eric ben is rather proud of angela
merkel's old certificates of achievement
and she's proud of the fact that her
student became the first female german
chancellor
[Music]
solanga here
why did it take so long in germany until
a woman made it to the top
it was because of the men
this was her elementary school
where did the straight a student's
ambition come from
to find out we stopped up at the house
of angel america's parents on the
outskirts of templin
she grew up here with her siblings her
mother a teacher wasn't allowed to work
in the gdr because her husband angela's
father was a pastor
it wasn't easy for the family
the east german regime often targeted
the church
we are meeting deacon wolfgang seyfried
he knew the chancellor's family he tells
us that little angela as a pastor's
daughter had to make a special effort to
get into university
that's how she learned to deal with
pressure
suffer less is quite an octopus
reliability and also perseverance
other than that she was somewhat well
adapted and of course a high achiever
she's a role model for young men and
women because at the end of the day
anything is possible if you just try
hard put in the effort and deliver
that's the bottom line
your role model
the only woman to win a nobel prize
twice marie curie
after finishing high school angela
merkel became a physicist and learned to
stand her ground in a male environment
the fall of the berlin wall in 1989
a turning point in merkel's life
for merkel german reunification was an
opportunity and she took advantage of it
in her mid-30s she entered the world of
politics
she was curious and full of energy
back in east germany she couldn't make
use of her skills
she realizes now i can add much more of
what's inside me to the outside world
the fact that she was able to make free
choices was certainly a big motivation
for her
what should i do now i don't have to be
patronized like back in east germany i
can find my own way and shape it
in just 10 years angela merkel launched
a stellar career with the conservative
cdu party supported by then chancellor
helmut cole she was named minister for
women's affairs
i swear so help me god
and three years later minister of the
environment
in the final days of the last government
of communist east germany did you ever
imagine yourself becoming a minister
here
no
no absolutely not
in the cdu party a largely male world
angel america was met with patriarchal
veges
did she even fit in
a child let's dive sea from east germany
a woman with ambitions
they called her cold skull and the wall
flower from the east
many women in germany recognize this
sexist treatment
that's
respect
disrespectful because she's accomplished
a lot if you look back at her story at
what she's achieved
she's a scientist so she's really smart
but that's the thing
calls little girl who can't get a
position without a male mentor what does
it tell us when such a picture is
presented to the public
but merkel endured it and waited for the
next door to open
her weapons expertise and perseverance
[Music]
at that time the cdu was predominantly
made up of catholic men who might have
studied law but sought a career in
politics from an early age
she was completely out of place there
not only because she came from the east
but also because she was a woman who
made a career change who had spent her
professional life in a completely
different field as a physicist
she did not know these gentlemen's
weapons and she realized very quickly
that she didn't need them she was able
to assert herself she prevailed against
these men with her own means
after the biggest donation scandal in
the cdu's history mercury managed to
emancipate herself from her mental call
and became the party's first ever female
leader
i accept the election some observers
believe that merkel hides her femininity
on purpose
so she isn't an easy target for sexist
comments
her uniform
simple blazers
and pants
after all having your cloth and looks
policed by strangers
is nothing new for most women
[Music]
she's often been attacked for her
femininity for example when she went to
the opera showing cleavage
then people discussed whether a female
chancellor should go somewhere showing
such cleavage
i can't imagine that something like that
would have been written or said about a
man
she was attacked for that a lot as a
result she never did it again
but all in all i think she realized that
she was getting into something that she
didn't want to get into
and maybe that's why approaching
feminism could have been a bit
detrimental
in fact angela merkel has shied away
from the term feminism for a long time
she initially didn't publicly speak up
for women's interests because she also
wanted to be elected by men it's very
simple it just doesn't suit her she
never had to fight for women's rights or
anything like that instead she accepted
the situation
and said okay i can simply improve
things for myself or do things
differently on a political level that is
reflected in the cdu party platform
so it was also about tactics in order to
stay in power america needed her party
support but the conservatives were still
miles away from a feminist agenda
you might remember merkel speaking at
the women's summit g20 a few years ago
which caused quite a stir
do you consider yourself a feminist
interesting reaction
[Applause]
to be honest
well
i'm not afraid if you think i'm a
feminist okay vote on it but i don't
want to adorn myself with that title but
over time something has changed
for merkel being a working woman was
normal
after all she grew up in the former east
germany where it was common for mothers
to work while the children were in
daycare
not so in west germany
for decades even in the 1990s when
germany was already reunited the cdu
supported a patriarchal view on gender
roles in which a husband works and earns
money and a wife stays at home with
children
these stereotypes have survived for a
long time working mothers in germany
were insulted called trabmuta raven
mothers meaning they were cruel and
uncaring with the help of her governing
coalition mackel is trying to confront
these prejudices
during mecca's time in office germany
has passed new laws aimed at more
progressive family structures and
policies for america this is not a
revolution but obvious
i believe that the basic understanding
of equality must be that on the one hand
women can move forward but that it's
also not a society in which nothing
changes for men in the meantime of
course different areas of life have to
be split up equally
under merkel parental leave and parental
benefits were introduced the
availability of daycare expanded
nationwide a new policy offered fathers
an extra two months pay when they take
parental leave
and the new regulation is supposed to
make returning to work easier for young
mothers
[Music]
and has all that worked
more women than ever before are living
off their own wages across germany
the country's employment rate among
women has risen by 13 since mackel took
office
billion of euros were invested in
expanding daycare facilities but
hundreds of thousands of daycare spots
for toddlers are still lacking
and it's still mostly women who opt out
of the career world because they have to
care for children
almost half of women in germany only
work outside their home part-time
[Music]
some 25 percent of men are now taking
parental leave and staying home with
their newborn children for an average of
three months
these figures have almost doubled since
2009.
it is important that it's not only the
woman who stays home but also the man
that women work that they don't just sit
around at home and look after the
children but that things change i think
that merkel has definitely made a big
contribution to that
these photos of female politicians with
babies in parliament have made headlines
globally
meanwhile in germany in 2018
a politician with your newborn baby was
thrown out of a regional parliamentary
chamber
despite many legal changes in reality
it's still hard for women in germany to
juggle family and career also in
parliament
we met up with green party mp francisca
brantner
she is part of new generation of female
politicians who want more than the
status quo she was instrumental in
getting a room set up in the bundestag
for breastfeeding and for children to
play
this is to play the children's room
uh-huh so we have enough spaces for them
to play to draw okay and this is the one
for breastfeeding
she has a daughter and wants parliament
to become more child friendly
there was a smoking room in the
bundestag but no place for children to
play or to stay
also you know there was no place you
could change your
your baby you know you didn't have that
here even though it was completely
normal in other parliaments across
europe
in mecca's era female politicians like
brantner are minority in the bundestag
which is still heavily dominated by men
in 2013 women still made up around 37 of
them peace but in the last four years
they only accounted for under a third
in this legislative period the bundestag
isn't exactly making history
that's also partly because of america's
parliamentary group the cdu and its
bavarian sister party csu are still
largely male dominated
during the last four years only around
20 of their bundestag mps were women and
there's the world of business
despite merkel being a role model women
are still underrepresented in leadership
positions holding only around 30 of such
posts in germany for a long time merkel
was against agenda parity quarter in
companies
having the state dictator companies goes
against america's ideals for freedom
she hoped that companies would
voluntarily bring more women into
management positions but that didn't
work out and michael introduced a gender
parity quota after all was it too late
[Music]
when i entered politics in 1990 i
honestly would have imagined everything
to be easier
during the miracle years more women have
served in higher political office than
ever before
including the kara defense minister and
her predecessor both
women
macca's closest advisors are also female
[Music]
we are meeting one of your four female
ministers of state dorothea
what does merkel do differently than her
male predecessors
half of our department heads are women
that does of course make a big
difference
it means that it's not only possible to
have a career in a leading position as a
woman
but it's also possible to lead a team
part time
when there are certain behaviors by men
this typical display of power she always
gives you the feeling of being a partner
a partner in crime she gives other women
the feeling that she doesn't let herself
be awed by it
she always inwardly rolls her eyes when
there's this kind of typical power
struggle when people speak for too long
when they interrupt
she always cuts to the chase in meetings
you can see that she just wants results
i think with women there's a certain
desire for efficiency
chancellory team has become increasingly
gender balanced over the last 16 years
but the world outside of the
chancellor's office is a different one
opposition politicians say the first
female german chancellor could and
should have done more with your power
well you know an effective fight against
violence against women financing
shelters a fight against inequality of
pay of women and men in germany women on
boards more effectively
fighting family child poverty
i haven't really seen her to push for
gender equality
at the un or at the eu level or within
germany so she hasn't been an advocate
for specific gender issues
be peace and woman
or being
you know and violence against women
worldwide i haven't actually seen her
being a champion of that either at home
or abroad but at the end of her last
term angela merkel seems to have let
loose and taken a more open stand for
women she no longer has to win an
election
just recently as your last main date is
coming to an end she publicly declared
herself a feminist
[Music]
in that sense i can say yes i'm a
feminist
we should all be feminists
[Applause]
despite all the criticism angela merkel
has indeed done more to promote gender
equality than all previous german
chancellors before her one person can't
change the whole system there are still
many challenges women face on a daily
basis especially single mothers
and the pandemic has again set back
gains to gender equity
but america's greatest legacy is
probably that she has shown that a woman
can do it
can lead the country through many crises
[Music]
today no one laughs at a girl when she
says that she wants to become a minister
or even chancellor
i've been told that there have even been
questions on whether men can also do
these jobs
i didn't make that up
she was perfect for being the first
female chancellor she couldn't fight all
the battles for us
now the next generation is coming and
will hopefully take over the fight for
women's rights
she just made sure that things are
running in the world
germany still has a long way to go to
achieve total gender equity one female
chancellor isn't enough of that so there
is still a lot to do
[Music]
you